[Applaus]
[Musik]
jahrzehntelang hat der dollar die
weltmärkte dominiert und wurde so zum
rückgrat des sogenannten horizontalen
imperiums der kapitalistischen us
wirtschaft wie andy kessler kommunist
ist urs fischer will es ausdrückt was
ein horizontales imperium ist und warum
es einem vertikal imperium wie dem
wladimir putins haushoch überlegen ist
werdet ihr am ende diese videos bender
verstehen aber eins nach dem anderen
heute geht es ja um die vorherrschaft
des dollars denn fakt ist die invasion
russlands in der ukraine und die daraus
resultierenden sanktionen der westlichen
demokratien gegen wladimir putins
machtapparat könnten den fundament dass
die globale hegemonie des dollars trägt
in der tat einen bedrohlichen riss
verpasst haben wieso nun die usa
großbritannien und europäische
institutionen haben einen beträchtlichen
teil der reserven der russischen
zentralbank in höhe von umgerechnet 630
milliarden us dollar eingefroren
moskauer sozusagen über nacht den
zugriff auf hunderte milliarden dollar
verloren
niemand der damit gerechnet hat dass der
westen sanktionen verhängen würde konnte
auch dies vorher sehen es war einfach
ein raubüberfall sergey lavrov russische
außenminister und das ist noch nicht
alles ermutigt von der us regierung
haben unternehmen wie visa mastercard
american express und die
finanzdienstleistungssparte von firmen
wie google und apple ihre tätigkeit in
russland eingestellt washington hat
außerdem mehreren russischen banken
darunter der sberbank der größten bank
des landes verboten mit dollars zu
handeln das ziel russland vom globale
finanzsystem abzuschneiden als strafe
verdient abscheulichen angriff träge
denen dieses land in der ukraine
entfesselt hat aber das ganze meine
lieben besucher politik zuschauer könnte
eine dramatische kehrseite haben
wenn du die regeln für russland ein dass
änderst du die regeln für die ganze welt
und sobald sich diese regel in dann
verändern sie das internationale
finanzwesen für immer mitglied professor
für finanzrecht an der universität von
virginia
das problem ist dass all diese maßnahmen
so einige fragen aufwerfen die sich
sicher auch schon viele von euch
gestellt haben können länder wie china
darauf vertrauen dass ich nicht dasselbe
schicksal erleiden werden wenn ja werden
sie dann nicht maßnahmen ergreifen um
sich von der macht des dollars
unabhängig zu machen könnte dies eine
ernsthafte bedrohung für die globale
vorherrschaft und angriffs selbst
währung darstellen nun in diesen neuen
video das in zusammenarbeit mit unserem
freund james cole entstanden ist dass
wir all diese fragen natürlich
beantworten und zwar gleich nach einer
kurzen werbebotschaft von unserem
sponsor es so ausschaut sagt bn ist ein
wirklich sicheres vpn dass sich auch
selbst zu meiner vollsten zufriedenheit
nutzen okay aber wozu braucht man
eigentlich ein virtual private networks
vpn nun da wären gleich mehrere vorteile
zum einen erschwert es in kombination
mit anderen vorkehrungen eure aktionen
im netz nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören es
bietet viele sicherheits features mit
denen ihr eure anonymität im netz wie
zum beispiel klien wird dass alle
cookies pop auf seiner fortgeschrittenen
etikettierung und nachverfolgung
mechanismen sich hier bloggt und die
damit verbundenen gefahren beseitigt
weiterer vorteil eines vpn ist dass ihr
so tun können als wer dir an einem
anderen ort so könnt ihr zum beispiel
auch wechselt und internet zuzugreifen
in dem land in dem er gerade seite ist
verfügbar wären ob daheim oder im urlaub
damit schlag die zensur und logging ein
schnippchen netflix und andere streaming
dienste die ihre inhalte nur in den usa
anbieten von europa ausnutzen oder
deutsches internet fernsehen im ausland
gucken mit surf kein problem aber das
ist noch lange nicht alles denn mit
einem softball könnt ihr wirklich alle
eure endgeräte lvbm registrieren handys
notebooks oder sogar ein smart tvs so
und wenn ihr den rabattcode politik.de
angibt bekommt ihr volksvorschlag autos
ein rabatt in höhe von 83 prozent und
obendrein ersten drei monate gratis dazu
denn links und dieses angebot findet ihr
in der beschreibung unter diesem video
also nichts wie los besorgt euch surft
und greift damit gleich welcher uns
finanziell unter die arme das gilt
übrigens auch direkt mit hilfe des
paypal spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls gehen die beschreibung gepackt
haben wir sind für jede unterstützung
dankbar denn damit helfen wir uns euch
in zukunft noch mehr und noch bessere
videos zu liefern so und nun zurück zu
unserer spannenden frage könnten die
folgen der sanktionen gegen russland
eine ernsthafte bedrohung für die
globale vorherrschaft des us dollars
darstellen lust ist
der einfluss des dollar
seit dem abkommen von bretton woods im
juli 1944 ist der dollar zur welt
reservewährung und leiter der
internationalen handel geworden in den
1960 er jahren der ehemalige
französische präsident valéry giscard
d'estaing als exorbitant das privileg
der vereinigten staaten
[Musik]
bretton woods hatte den folgenden
grundgedanken der dollar ist an den
goldpreis gebunden während alle anderen
währungen an den dollar selbst gekoppelt
sind ein szenario das sich 1971 komplett
änderte als richard nixon den
goldstandard aufgabe und die
konvertierbarkeit der us-währung
vollständig und für immer aus setzte
[Musik]
außerdem bilden die neuen virtuellen
dollars nach wie vor das rückgrat des
modernen bankensystems eines systems das
nicht mehr durch edelmetalle gestützt
wird sondern in erster linie durch das
vertrauen in die stärke der us
wirtschaft in die fähigkeit us-regierung
ihren zahlungsverpflichtungen
nachzukommen und auch der macht ihre
gewaltigen kriegsmaschinerie das erklärt
warum der dollar im internationalen
handel bei finanztransaktionen und bei
den zentralbanken noch immer die mit
abstand meistgenutzte währung ist mit
anderen worten werden oder dass vor
diesem hintergrund wagen die hegemonie
und bonität des dollars infrage zu
stellen nun liebe politik zuschauer dies
war im grunde die vorherrschte denkweise
der letzten jahrzehnte welche dazu
führte dass 60 prozent der weltweiten
devisenreserven in höhe von 12,8
millionen dollar eben in us dollars
vorgehalten werden schaut euch einfach
mal bringen
[Musik]
man muss nicht lange recherchieren um
herauszufinden dass zb die volksrepublik
china mehr als eine billion dollar an
us-staatsanleihen in ihren reserven hält
womit sie nach japan der zweitgrößte
ausländische gläubiger von hat sms
insgesamt über staatsanleihen hinaus
könnte das auch dollar laufen die
chinesische vermögen jedoch fast zwei
billionen betragen die bedeutung des
dollars ist so groß dass länder die ihre
dollar reserven aufbrauchen in der regel
einen schmerzhaften finanziellen
zusammenbruch erleiden genau das ist zum
beispiel südkorea thailand und auch
russland während der krise in der 1990
er jahre passiert aber das wäre ein
thema für ein ganz eigenes video
[Musik]
tatsache ist dass sowohl china als auch
insbesondere russland 2018 versuchen
ihre abhängigkeit vom dollar
schrittweise zu verringern bislang ist
ihnen das allerdings nur zum teil
gelungen die chinesische regierung
betrachtet die derzeitige position des
dollars als eines der bollwerke der us
macht deshalb soll sich das langfristige
ziel ihrer eigenen währung den yuan
immer viel wichtigere rolle im globalen
finanzsystems zukommen zu lassen
[Musik]
die russische invasion in der ukraine
und die gegen die russische regierung
verhängten sanktionen insbesondere dass
ein student hätte diesen reserven des
landes könnten diese pläne beschleunigen
dies ist zumindest das risiko auf das
viele experten analysten hingewiesen
haben und tatsächlich sprach sich die
ehemalige vize präsidentin der bank of
china die an ihrer linken ende märz 2022
öffentlich dafür aus dass china den rest
der welt dabei unterstützen sollte die
dominanz des dollars abzuschütteln dabei
sprach sie auch unverblümt über die
folgen des kriegs in der ukraine
nur stehst aktionen werden die usa ihre
glaubwürdigkeit verlieren und die
langfristige hegemonie des dollar
untergraben denn natürlich geht es nicht
nur um china viele autokraten und
tyrannen und populistische führe auf der
ganzen welt würden sich über diesen
richtungswechsel gewaltig freuen die
frage lautet also wird der ausschluss
russlands aus dem dualen system den
anfang vom ende des dollars als
internationale reservewährung einläuten
werden sich russland und china darauf
einigen den yuan einzuführen oder auf
crypto währungen umzusteigen wird es
ihnen gelingen andere staaten
mitzureißen und damit die sanktionen
gegen russland in einer art historischen
wendepunkt zu verwandeln einen
wendepunkt den der besten noch bereuen
wird nun an dieser stelle müssen wir in
die details eintauchen denn die dinge
könnten viel komplizierter sein als ist
auf den ersten blick aussieht
die drei großen stärken des us dollar
eine tatsache müssen wir unbedingt
gegenwärtigen selbst auch nur ein
teilweiser verlust des status als
reservewährung wäre für die
us-wirtschaft ein schwerer schlag dem
schlimmsten fall würde eine abwertung
des dollars die zu einem massiven
verkauf von grünbergs führen würde die
inflation auf einen usa noch nie
dagewesenes niveau ansteigen lassen die
kaufkraft der haushalte und import
abhängigen unternehmen würde
wahrscheinlich eine starke korrektur
erfahren und kapitalabflüsse könnten die
finanzmärkte erheblich in
mitleidenschaft ziehen
kriege stellen auch die vorherrschaft
von währungen in fragen unterstützen das
entstehen neuer währungssysteme sollten
post analyst bei der credit suisse habe
handelt es sich hierbei wirklich um ein
realistisches szenario könnten die
wieder sache des us-dollars ihren plan
tatsächlich umsetzen nun die wahrheit
ist dass dies heute also sehr
unwahrscheinliche fast unmöglich
erscheint warum nun weil wir die drei
großen vorteile die drei großen stärken
die angriffe währung auszeichnen in
betracht ziehen müssen
eine sehr wichtiger faktor ist
liquidität das heißt es muss erst mal
ausreichend geld vorhanden sein und
damit sowohl alle transaktionen als auch
den anlage und reserve bedarf der
marktakteure zu befriedigen das problem
ist außerhalb europas japans und vor
allem der usa gibt es einfach keine
ausreichende menge an liquiden
finanzmitteln welche diese enorme
nachfrage befriedigen und damit den
dollar ersetzen könnte außerdem haben
praktisch alle ländern mit wichtigen
internationalen währungen mit ausnahme
chinas die sanktionen gegen russland
unterstützt was ja eher ein
vertrauensbeweis für die us währung aber
auch den euro darstellt im fall des yuan
müssen wir außerdem berücksichtigen dass
chinas kapitalmarkt kein offener markt
ist diese währung ist wieder frei
konvertierbar noch entspricht halt grad
mehr rechtssicherheit in china dem der
vereinigten staaten und zwar bei weitem
nicht vorläufig oder zumindest wenn nahe
zukunft kommt sie somit für viele
akteure auch staaten oder unternehmen
allein schon deswegen nicht als
dominante reservewährung infrage
außerdem müssen wir denken dass
investitionen in andere kleine währungen
ein erhebliches finanzielles und auch
politisches risiko mit sich bringen
können und gerade russland ist ein gutes
beispiel dafür die in chinesischem
besitz befindlichen rubel verloren
zunächst 40 prozent an wert um sie
später wieder zu erholen aber nur weil
in russland umfangreiche kapitalmarkt
kontrollen eingeführt wurden die den
gebrauch dieser währung sowieso stark
einschränken der hobel ist seitdem eine
potente währung dem markt wird durch
quote manipulation ein hoher kurs
vorgegaukelt welcher jedoch bei einer
rückkehr zu normalen marktmechanismen
die eine gesunde volkswirtschaft
ausmachen und wie ein kartenhaus
zusammenbrechen würde denn was kann man
mit einer solchen währung anfang außer
in russland rohstoffe einzukaufen
aufgrund der zahlreichen beschränkungen
kann man sie zum kauf von
vermögenswerten und produkten auf der
ganzen welt kaum verwenden und das wird
sich auch so schnell nicht ändern eine
denkbare alternative der krypto
währungen aber auch sie scheint heute
nicht annähernd wann ist solche aufgabe
geeignet oder vorbereitet zu sein zumal
gerade regierungen wie die chinesische
ganz und gar nicht angetan sind von
dieser art unabhängiger vermögenswerte
die uns von txtr september 2021 china
verbietet alle crypto währungs
transaktionen
[Musik]
kommen wir also zum zweiten wichtigen
grund warum der dollar nicht so schnell
verdrängt werden kann die usa scheint es
zurzeit ökonomisch besser zu gehen als
ihren europäischen konkurrenten der
chinesischen wirtschaft und sogar nimmt
anderen großen asiatischen
volkswirtschaften genau aus diesem grund
ist die federal reserve in der lage bei
der straffung der im letzten jahrzehnte
weltweit extrem lockeren geldpolitik die
führung oder den großen zentralbanken zu
übernehmen im gegensatz dazu scheint die
chinesische zentralbank bereit oder
sogar benötigt zu sein den umgekehrten
weg zu gehen um den immer stärker
kränkelnde wirtschaft china ist
anzukurbeln während die us zentralbank
ihre leitzinsen nun beständig anhebt
liegt die chinesische eine drastische
senkung nach der anderen sind und
natürlich würden relativ höhere zinsen
die position des dollars in den nächsten
jahren stärken und ja wir reden hier
über das ewige auf und ab der
konjunkturzyklen aber wir müssen uns da
gegenwärtigen dass die wirtschaft chinas
vor gewaltigen problemen steht etwas
worüber wir schon in vielen
vorangegangenen videos berichtet haben
peking befindet sich im moment daher
nicht gerade in einer pole position aus
der es zum angriff auf den dollar blasen
könnte es braucht die volkswirtschaften
der usa und europas mehr denn je als zug
motoren um den eigenen karren wieder aus
dem dreck zu ziehen eine tatsache die
den besten helfen könnte die
auswirkungen der sanktionen gegen
russland auf die eigenen
volkswirtschaften besser zu überwinden
[Musik]
bei weniger ist möglich ist jedoch die
dritte große stärke des dollars er wird
von einer viel besser gefüllten
wirtschaft und einer jüngeren
bevölkerung gestützt vergessen wir nicht
dass in jüngster zeit alle modernen
technologischen revolutionen epizentrum
in den usa hatten von der digitalen
wirtschaft über die biotechnologie bis
hin zur medizinischen forschung in china
war sehr gut in nachahmen aber zu aber
und gar zu einer brutstätte für wirklich
disruptive und revolutionäre
innovationen konnte es bislang nicht
werden außerdem könnten in den usa auch
andere für das land und seine globale
wettbewerbsfähigkeit sehr wichtige
sektoren in den kommenden jahren so
richtig durchstarten was ich damit meine
nun zb erdöl gas und rüstung
die usa exportierten 2021 eine
rekordmenge an flüssigerdgas
us-amerikanische lng exporteure sind die
großen gewinner der europäischen erdgas
krise
japan plant rekord verteidigungsausgaben
im jahr 2022 mit der zehnten erhöhung in
folge
deutschland will ein 100 milliarden euro
vor einrichten um seine militärische
stärke zu erhöhen bundeskanzler olaf
scholz sagt dass die dringlichkeit der
ukraine krise die entscheidung zur
erhöhung der verteidigungsausgaben
erzwungen habe tatsache ist dass das
bisher einzige strukturell element dass
der relativen position des dollar
schaden scheint das wohl stresstests
welches die spielräume der
us-bundesregierung einschränkt aber vor
dem hintergrund all dieser faktoren
lautet oder fast ganz klar alles deutet
darauf hin dass die sanktionen gegen
russland die dominanz des dollars nicht
gefährden werden zumindest nicht sofort
und auch nicht mittelfristig
das hinter die usa natürlich nicht daran
sich noch weiter um die verbesserung
ihrer wettbewerbsposition zu kümmern zum
beispiel indem sie das defizit der
öffentlichen haushalte reduzieren oder
mehr ausländische talente anziehen denn
die größte gefahr für die macht des
dollars liegt tatsächlich darin sich auf
den eigenen lorbeeren auszuruhen nicht
umsonst waren internationale
organisationen wie der internationale
währungsfonds seit jahren davor dass der
dollar allmählich an einfluss in der
welt verliert der iwf hat dies als
schleichende erosion des dollars
bezeichnet ein prozess der dazu geführt
hat dass der anteil der in dollar
ausgewiesen weltweiten währungsreserven
seitdem in den neunziger jahre bis heute
von 71 prozent auf 59 prozent gesunken
ist aber wie gesagt zur zeit dort
trotzdem alles darauf hin dass die
dominanz des dollars noch viele jahre
andauern wird die tatsache welche auch
auf den horizontalen imperium der us
wirtschaft basiert ja genau am anfang
des videos habe ich ja versprochen euch
zu erklären was denn ein horizontales
oder vertikales imperium ist und eure
geduld sollen nun belohnt werden
[Musik]
die weltwirtschaft durch licht in den
letzten jahrzehnten einen erheblichen
wandel der vor allem davon geprägt war
das unternehmen zusehends auf einzelnen
domäne der wertschöpfung spezialisiert
haben um darin ihre konkurrenzfähigkeit
zu steigern standardisierung
digitalisierung und die globale
vernetzung von informationen und
logistik ermöglichte es ihnen zum
beispiel die entwicklung und vermarktung
von produkten vor der produktion selbst
zu trennen dadurch wurden die alten
konzerns ziellos aufgebrochen die
weltwirtschaft wurde horizontal und
organisierte sich in stapeln von
unternehmen branchen und sogar ländern
in die märkte auf der grundlage ihrer
spezialisierten wertschöpfung kapital
zur verfügung stellten ein klassisches
beispiel ist die automobilbranche in
welch ein erheblicher teil der
wertschöpfung im gewaltigen ökosystem
viele spezialisierte zulieferer erbracht
wird die großen marken definieren doch
das design die gesamt spezifikation und
fügen dann alles zusammen noch weiter
geht zum beispiel apple s entwickelt das
betriebssystem für seine telefone lässt
diese aber komplett von foxconn mit
koreanischen bildschirmen und
taiwanesischen chips in china
produzieren auf ähnliche weise hatte
bereits 30 jahre zuvor in der
pc-industrie die vielen horizontal
angeordnete unternehmen wie microsoft
intel und amd zusammen mit dell und hp
und komponenten und chip hersteller aus
taiwan singapur japan das vertikal
integrierte imperium des mainstream
hersteller ist ibm zu sturz gebracht in
der heutigen welt sind eben nicht jene
unternehmen erfolgreich den gesamten
wertschöpfungsprozess in ihren eigenen
besitz haben sondern jene die ihre
ressourcen auf die
geschäftsmöglichkeiten konzentrieren in
denen sie am besten sind ihr erfolg
zeigt dass die welt jetzt in horizontale
scheiben aufgeteilt ist wobei die
produktivsten ganz oben sitzen apple
google microsoft und amazon verfügen
alle über eine marktkapitalisierung die
jeweils größer ist als das russische bip
das amerikanische wirtschafts
imperialismus
sonntages imperium oder auf der anderen
seite versucht ein vladimir putin das
vertikale imperium des probiert union
wieder herzustellen ein versuch über den
wir schon in mehreren videos gesprochen
haben und der unserer ansicht nach klar
zum scheitern verurteilt ist
denn rohstoffe kommen und gehen ebenso
wie die aus ihrem verkauf erlösten
reichtümer die treibende kraft des
fortschritts jedoch ist die
produktivität der zentralistisch
planwirtschaftliche einheitsbrei wird
keine chance haben gegen als sich selbst
organisierende auf kapitalistischen
anreißen basierendes system in dem sich
jeder seinen platz verdienen muss
seitdem denkt schöppingen dieses prinzip
erkannt und in china eingeführt hatte
hat es nicht nur 114 millionen menschen
braucht der armut befreit sondern auch
die kapitel selbst an der macht gehalten
da sie ihren führungsanspruch auf den
darauf fußenden wirtschaftlichen
erfolgen neu gegründete
unterschiedlichen ping fühlt sich das
regime jedoch zunehmend von der
horizontal ead.etr eigenen wirtschaft
bedroht führende köpfe werden zu
schweigen gebracht die menschen in den
weltoffenen hightech-metropole durch
drastische lockdown unterdrückt ja es
wurde sogar das spielen von videospielen
eingeschränkt und nachhilfeunterricht
verboten die partei übernahm die volle
kontrolle über den zugang der menschen
zu informationen alles worum es geht ist
die konzentration der eigenen macht
china geht so törichter weise in die
vertikale über und riskiert damit die
basis seiner eigenen macht in der welt
und das ist eine schlechte nachricht für
unser aller wohlstand aber eher eine
gute die weltweite dominanz des
us-dollar aber jetzt seid ihr an der
reihe welches imperium wird in zukunft
siegen das vertikale oder horizontale
wie schätzen die chancen des dollars in
den turbulenten zeiten ein die auf uns
zukommen werden glaubt ihr dass crypto
währungen eines tages das rückgrat des
internationalen finanzsystems sein
könnten und welches fokussiert ihr für
den chinesischen yuan könnte er an die
stelle des dollars treten wie immer sind
wir schon auf eure beiträge im
kommentarbereich gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen vielleicht
das gelernt habt weiß ja das kann ein
glas mit freunden und wissen das aber
mit glöckchen und keines unserer videos
messer verpassen natürlich von der sache
das hat aber eine spende von euch mit
dem sls projekte weiterzuführen in paper
link dazu findet ihr wie immer in der
beschreibung mit dem video macht gut und
mit
[Musik]